- [Narrator] On average,
flat roads like this
cost around $1 million
per lane mile to build.
But these winding mountain roads
can cost up to 10 times that.
That's because...
- You can't just excavate
rock. You have to blast.
(rocks crashing)
- [Narrator] And that's really expensive,
which is one of the reasons
why brand new mountain roads
aren't built very often.
- We only wanna design
and build them once.
- [Narrator] We asked
a structural engineer
with over 25 years of experience
to explain how these steep
inclines and sharp turns
are designed to keep drivers
safe in the mountains.
- There's a lot of different
kinds of mountain roads.
I think as a tourist,
a lot of people think
of the very narrow, windy mountain roads.
But additionally, you have interstates
going through the mountains
and those are mountain roads.
- [Narrator] Heffron says
that digging a tunnel
through the mountain is usually
expensive and highly risky.
So, managing that vertical climb is key.
- That's what we call
the grade of the road,
and we talk about it in percentages.
So, for every hundred feet you travel,
you wanna try to keep it to five feet max.
In the mountains,
a lot of times you're
going to exceed that.
You may go 6.5 or even 10%.
- [Narrator] Mountain
roads also have to maneuver
around a lot of natural obstacles,
affecting its path or
horizontal alignment.
- When you get to a mountain setting,
the edges of your roadway
are defined by nature.
One of the things you're trying to define
is how wide will the roadway be?
We may decide to narrow the
lane widths up to 11 feet
so that we can stay out of the creek,
or not have to blast
into the adjacent rock.
And these things are pretty
imperceptible to the driver.
You don't really get a tape measure out
every a hundred feet, but
as a designer, you do.
- [Narrator] When the
terrain gets too steep,
switchbacks become necessary.
Heffron says these tighter
turns also help reduce
how much the mountain side
is affected by the road.
- On a more rural low volume road,
you may have more switchbacks
and tighter turns.
It's a nice 200 foot radius
to make that switchback
and get around that curve.
Whereas on an interstate,
instead of 200, you have 1,000.
About five times that.
- [Narrator] When the road curves,
there's usually an added design feature
called superelevation,
which is where the roadway
is tilted to make it
easier to navigate a curve.
- So, as you're entering
a curve as a driver,
and you're turning,
the roadway isn't flat,
but it's going to super elevate,
it's going to raise on the high side.
Kinda like you see at a speed track.
The centripetal force will
keep you on the roadway.
- [Narrator] Superelevation
is especially important
in the mountains where
roads get icy quickly.
- If the roadway were flat,
especially if this roadway is icy,
you could veer off the roadway.
- [Narrator] Heffron says
superelevation starts at around 2%
and gets steeper as the speed
of the roadway increases.
- Sometimes in the mountains
you'll go 5, 6%, maybe 8,
but you're trying to keep it not too steep
because as this roadway ice is over,
and if there's a lot of
traffic during a snowstorm
and the cars go slower,
and they might have the
propensity to slide horizontally,
which is not safe.
- [Narrator] Rock fall
makes mountain road design
even more challenging.
(rocks crashing)
- A lot of rock stability and rockfall
is controlled specifically
by the geometry.
- [Narrator] This is Howard Hume.
His job is to identify these.
The breaks in the rock face,
also called rock joints and...
- How they interact with the face angle.
Whether they project outta the slope,
in which case they're a problem,
in which case you've gotta stop them.
You can see horizontal
jointing in the face.
- [Narrator] Hume says the stability
of rock faces varies widely.
But in general, if rock
joints are horizontal
or at a very low angle
with respect to the road...
- That's not a problem.
If it's dipping steeply and
you're standing underneath it,
that's definitely a problem.
- [Narrator] Hume and his team use a drone
to take hundreds or
even thousands of photos
of the rock face.
- You got the area over there.
- [Narrator] To create
models like this and this,
which he uses to simulate
different types of rockfall.
This helps him decide
the most stable angle
to cut the rock face.
- When I say cut,
eventually rock like this,
you've gotta blast it.
(rocks exploding)
- [Narrator] And then,
there's the surrounding water
that engineers have to deal with.
- As the water is coming
down from the mountainside,
it's moving fast.
- [Narrator] To manage this, Heffron says
there are various drainage
systems like this or this.
- A lot of times you'll see kind of a pipe
sticking out from the side of the road,
and it comes out here and drains
away from the roadway into the creek.
- [Narrator] A lot of mountain roads
started out as wagon trails,
which generally followed
streams and creeks.
This was often the
easiest and cheapest way
to get through the terrain.
Over time, those wagon
trails were adjusted
and widened to fit automobiles.
But being so close to
water means designers
have to add elements like...
- Riprap.
Riprap is just big rocks placed in a way
such that it helps stabilize and maintain
the side of the creek,
which is supporting the
side of your roadway.
- [Narrator] Water mitigation also helps
prevent soil erosion,
which can be extremely
dangerous for mountain roads.
(siren wailing)
In 2020, a wildfire
burned over 30,000 acres
in Colorado's Glenwood Canyon.
And because there was no vegetation,
the storms that hit the
area the following year
caused repeated flooding and debris flow
that shut down a section of the interstate
for about two weeks.
- I-70 is closed once
again in Glenwood Canyon,
this time for five mudslides
covering hundreds of feet of highway.
- [Narrator] Even though mountain roads
often have more variables than flat roads,
Heffron says Consistency
is still the goal.
- We're gonna have some steep turns.
But if all of a sudden in our design
we interject along the
roadway a very steep turn,
then your safety overall goes down
because of the lack of consistency.
As people are traveling a mountain road,
you don't want them to think
about the infrastructure.
You want them to think about
the beauty of the nature
that they're traveling through.
You're getting the full
experience. It's snowing.
(laughs softly)
(gentle music)